[Music]
good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation this is the first of
innocence to talks that have to do with
thinking about the future Paulin away is
lucky to be going first because the next
one is Nassim Nicholas Taleb doing the
Black Swan and Talib is about
he'll be here Monday February 4th is
about the huge events that no matter how
hard you try you can't predict and that
change everything and the way he comes
to engaging that is by looking he's a
quant he's a financial analyst
mathematical type as well as Lebanese as
well as great storyteller
and what he's doing is looking at the
past in a certain way and trying to
identify all the illusions that we use
the past to think about the future with
Sappho whose background is in studying
the history of Technology also looks at
the past looking for all the kinds of
illusions which we delude ourselves
about the future at a more micro
more micro scale than talib does but
there's interesting consistencies and
apparent contradictions but they're
probably just paradoxical between the
two so let's start with Paul Sappho
Thank You Stuart and it's wonderful to
be here and it is interesting to be on
the stage ahead of talib because it's a
funny thing these things go in cycles
but it is fashionable at the moment to
make fun of futurists and forecasts and
make great sport about how people's
predictions and forecasts are terrible
which I have no objection to I've done
it myself for the better part of 25
years as a professional in the field and
I've even taken pain taking great pains
not to call myself a futurist which I
will probably get around to explain you
in a little bit but but let me start
with a forecast and that was made a
couple of years ago and just analyzed it
a little bit
hunt for bin Laden experts agree al
Qaeda leader is dead or alive now on the
surface this would look like a terrible
forecast in in fact I'm not even sure if
it's a real forecast this was courtesy
of a jokester friend of mine Yossi Vardi
who sent it my way and I've never gotten
CNN to admit if they actually did this
but let's assume it wasn't real forecast
you know it's evocative the complaint
that one of our former presidents once
said please give me a one-handed
economist you know none of this on the
one hand on the other hand thing I would
actually argue that this is not just a
good forecast this is a great forecast
because it accurately and completely
captured the uncertainty of that moment
the answer is the old dead or alive
beats me that's what it says and the
biggest mistake of forecaster can miss
make is to pretend to be more certain
than in fact this fact suggests and it
goes even more deeply than that and I
think especially important today this
moment in time this very uncertain
moment in time where uncertainty just
seems to be everywhere and the
indicators head off in opposite
directions take take the financial
markets a few weeks ago watching gold
and Google both go upwards you know and
the question was which one would cross
850 first 850 being the 30-year record
high for gold
well the spot on gold made it today it
hit $900 but you know it's a funny thing
once upon a time and in more simple and
innocent times if stock prices were high
like Google's price that men times were
good and if gold prices were high like
gold is at the moment that mint times
are bad both are high go figure
and then there's oil headed over $100
now it's under what happens next the
mortgage crisis and anybody who's been
in Europe lately knows what the euro is
doing and
you think twice before ordering a latte
in Paris these indicators are headed in
opposite directions and in my business
is a forecaster when change clusters at
the extremes it's a certain bet that
much more fundamental change lies ahead
and I'll talk a little bit about what I
think lies ahead tonight but mostly what
I want to do is share with you some
tricks of the trade some rules of thumb
that I've learned over the last 25 years
as a forecaster and show you a little
bit of how I approach dealing with
looking at this uncertainty and then
certainty really is the key element the
way I think about it is you can take an
event at a given moment in time and
extending outwards from that event is a
cone of uncertainty and the act of
forecasting amounts to the act of
mapping that cone of uncertainty and it
is an act of embracing uncertainty and
above all by the way it is an act that
everybody should do in these uncertain
times forecasting is more important than
ever and the biggest mistake you can
make is to lead it leave it to the
experts
everybody should forecast for themselves
and if you do that regardless of the
quality your forecasts you will be a
more sophisticated consumer of the
forecasts from the people who do it on a
full-time basis the trick with a cone of
uncertainty and by the way the reason
why it's a cone it's pure common sense
in fact everything I'm going to talk
about tonight is common sense and
because it's common sense very little of
it is original think about the weather
in San Francisco you know it's our
weather is not the best example but you
know the cone 15 minutes out is fairly
narrow it's a safe bet unless you live
in Marin what the weather will be but go
out a day the cone gets broader and then
after a couple of days about three days
well the curtain of good information
falls and it's like anyone's guess so
the essence of this is you're thinking
about that spread
of uncertainty that increases over time
and it begins with an event and it
forces you to think about just what the
uncertainty really is by the way just a
footnote I forecast
I don't predict you know at a cocktail
party so I'm going to come up and they
say so you know usually the question is
so how are your predictions done
actually the first question is what
stock should I buy that's the most
boring question but the second why did I
start it is a great conversation killer
because I say I actually don't predict I
forecasts and that's about mapping a
cone of uncertainty and they find
someone else to talk to it works works
every time
but in uncertainty is not just an
artifact of imperfect foresight
uncertainty is intrinsic in the process
and in my opinion it's very good news
think about it a world of no uncertainty
a world in which you really or somebody
could accurately predict he's a world
that I don't think any of us would
really want to live in that's the world
of a fundamentalist religious believer
God has a plan it's all written out but
why bother because you can't change it
that's the world of the appointment in
Samarra if you remember that old tale of
the servant who goes to the souk and
Samarra and bumps into death in the
marketplace comes rushing home agitated
and says to his master master master
lend me your horse I must flee to
Baghdad and the master says why he said
well death was menacing me in the
marketplace so the servant rides off the
master goes into the marketplace finds
death he's really easy to pick out black
hood you know big and says dude what are
you doing messing with my servants he
said I wasn't threatening your servant I
was just startled to see him because we
have an appointment in Samarra tonight
so that's not the world we live in this
is a world of uncertainty and that's
good news because uncertainty is opera
tunity anybody who invests in the stock
market you know the worst market to
invest in is a market where there's no
changes just painful if you call it
wrong but their uncertainty and
opportunity go together and in a
perverse sort of way that means this is
the best of all possible times now
admittedly you know for some people
especially if you invested in subprime
mortgages saying that today is the best
of all possible times is evocative of
the immortal words of John Jacob Astor
who while sitting in the bar of the SS
Titanic said you know I asked rice but
this is ridiculous
nonetheless the art of forecasting is
understanding uncertainty and also
balancing between a stance where if you
look at things too narrowly if you draw
that cone too narrowly you're going to
miss things that happen if you broad
draw it too broadly you're going to
spend your whole time navel gazing
around events that may never come to
pass and the art what makes forecasting
heart isn't predicting the outcome what
makes forecasting hard is predicting the
edges of the cone and nobody I've been
saying this for 25 years and nobody
seems to get it maybe I just don't know
how to talk here is a way to think about
it
wildcards are an especially effective
method to do this and this is the first
of a couple of rules I did an article in
Harvard Business Review and I pulled a
little bit out of this but out of
respect for you all I've thrown out a
bunch of stuff I didn't do put into hvr
think about wildcards you know Peter
Schwartz a brilliant futurist
is fond of remarking that the difference
between a good forecast and reality is
that a good forecast has to be
believable and internally consistent and
of course reality Labor's under no such
constraints and and one way to think
about that the unlikely the outlandish
and the like is to turn them into wild
cards wild cards are a permissible way
think crazy ideas without getting
ridiculed and and there are all sorts of
ways to think about wildcards but the
bottom line is that wildcards
test the edge of the cone they define
the ragged edge of plausibility of any
good forecast
so think about wildcards in and think
about people who do it well John
Peterson at the Arlington Institute on
the East Coast is a brilliant thinker
about wildcards but of course the daily
newspaper is a great source of wildcards
and and just being a smartypants is not
a bad idea I remember when we started
the recall campaign for governor
long before Schwarzenegger appeared on
scene and I was talking to a journalist
friend on the East Coast and I called
him up I said you know we're having a
recall campaign again and we've had one
of these ever since Hiram Johnson ran
for governor but I just have this
feeling this one's gonna work and you
know with our damn luck we're gonna get
another damn movie actor as governor he
thinks I'm a genius I was just being a
smartass and of course the amazing part
about that wild card is not only did we
get a governor a next movie actor as
governor he's a great governor go figure
so you know the difference released a
pretty good governor so the bottom line
is think about wild cards and look
around in all sorts of places I find
they they pop out in in the odd sorts of
spots but but also bad forecasts really
bad forecasts can be really great wild
cards this is a magazine it's one of my
favorite magazines fact it was my most
favorite magazine until the advent of
Wired which was kind of an act of
unrequited love because it lasted
exactly one issue as I said there hasn't
been a magazine like this one until now
and there wasn't one after it was around
1970 they didn't put a date on it so I
can't but you can judge that's of the
age by the picture that's a very young
al Toffler before he wrote future shock
go so so bad magazines with lurid
cats are a great place to look for good
wildcards and in this they had a special
because it was like 1969-1970 they had a
newspaper from 1984 and there was a want
ads section in it for 1984 genetic
engineer need MS and biochemistry and
lab experience will be editing and
composing genetic ie DNA because people
didn't know about codes for babies
Skinner Community Hospital Watson Avenue
this was you know this was a good seven
years before the first issue of
biotechnology appeared on screen the
other ones are pretty good to attractive
girls with good personalities and basic
office skills needed for film about
sexism in the 70s it's wonderful stuff
and I must admit I look at this old
magazine more often than you might
imagine
wild cards sensitize us to surprise they
help us kind of get in underneath the
current of the zeitgeist and get a sense
of what's going on and by the way there
is one other source I should mention not
just for wild cards but but for forecast
and that's science fiction science
fiction people have real arguments about
whether it's a good place for
forecasting it's actually one of the few
things that will actually give you
predictive power because it turns out
science science fiction ends up being
this idea bomb it's a meme bomb that
goes into the head of teenagers and they
carry that idea through school ignoring
their professors and ignoring their
bosses until they reach middle age and
they get the opportunity to finally
carry out their dreams which they got
from reading science fiction and that's
how we got cyberspace bill Gibson you
know
famously wrote about it in a novel and
the people who read it when they got
into the business world that's what they
made and the Atomic Scientists who
worked on the Manhattan Project were all
influenced by HG Wells and many of the
astronauts in the mercury program grew
up on space opera so science fiction is
actually a really interesting special
case of how to look ahead because you
can see what peep
dreams are and they'll eventually get a
chance to do it but go back to this
notion a surprise things surprise us for
a very simple reason and that is change
is never linear at least interesting
change is never linear even in here in
Silicon Valley what surprises me is that
the future constantly arrives late and
in unexpected ways fact the secret in
Silicon Valley is most ideas take 20
years to become an overnight success and
they do so because change looks like
this it's an s-curve it's the curve of
Moore's law we all know the doubling
period of chips and it's led to all the
marvels we have all sorts of consumer
devices television following an s-curve
pattern from invention in in the 1930s
to take off in the 1950s the internet
itself followed an s-curve I mean the
internet was almost exactly 20 years old
in 1987 the Year Al Gore invented it
when it started to take off so s curves
are everywhere they are all around us
and as a forecaster in general a safe
posture is things are going to arrive
late and and all the the other half of
that statement will spoil a slide a few
points ahead if everybody thinks
something's around the corner take the
Posche of no no no no it's it's further
out and then if they all say it'll never
arrive you can say it's about to come
guarantee that's a safe default position
but but let me give you an example
because inflection points are tiptoeing
past us all the time but the problem is
this is how we generally look at the
future we even in Silicon Valley people
draw the future is a straight line and
meanwhile things go here and it's
because we don't like change and and a
few other details about why that flat
spot so flat but let me give you an
example of an inflection point tiptoeing
past us right now this is a picture I
shot in May 2004 at the first DARPA
Grand Challenge this is the robotic race
across the desert 150 miles
one team's qualified and I was there at
the start and this is sort of what
happened at the start it was like Monty
Python 21 teams all but four vehicles
died in the shoots are at the gate and
and this one was my favorite his little
r2d2 kind of guy comes out the jersey
barriers it gets to the entrance it
pauses it looks left it looks right it
thinks about it a bit and it hangs a
hard left and dies in a coyote bush 20
feet the robot that got furthest was
this one sandstorm from Carnegie Mellon
here it is
yeah you've lost dudes get over it
but it's a nice vehicle and and you
won't whistle when you see the next
picture so as and and by the way for
those of you aren't familiar with race
so this is a Humvee with a lidar unit on
the on the roof and behind it is a truck
with three dudes in it and one dudes
driving and one dudes got his thumb on a
kill switch at the moment the robot
misbehaves he like you're dead there was
one a huge military vehicle that was the
scariest thing I've ever seen that they
really had to shut down but I don't want
to pound out so the next picture is the
n stormy you know I kept trying to think
what's the punchline - why did the robot
cross the road but I can't recall this
is a picture of it crossing the road
moments before it drove through a fence
people if those people had known they
would have been stepping about 50 feet
farther back and that little inset
picture is sandstorm stuck on the side
of the road where it died seven point
four miles into the race now I was part
there as part of a medical support team
and we were halfway on the race out in
the desert feeling pretty darn foolish
because there was nothing near us but
now jump and and only four four robots
got out of the gates jump ahead 18
months later and here's the finish of
this second race the Grand Challenge
number two and that is Stanley from
Stanford and as a part-time consulting
professor at Stanford
I'm glad to say the Stanford team won
but I will in the interest of the
Carnegie Mellon folks in back admit it's
not so much that Stanford one but
Carnegie Mellon lost and only by a small
amount it's off topic but let me explain
it for software developers in the room
sandstorm Carnegie Mellon team leader is
red whitaker reds and exper een let me
correct myself Reds a marine there is no
such thing as an ex-marine he believes
in hot hardware thinks good hardware's
more important than good software
sebastian thron who led the Stanford
team and by the way we at Stanford stole
sebastian from the Carnegie Mellon team
and moved him out to Stanford where he's
the head of the AI lab believes in
really good software and will make up
for bad software sandstorm was kickin
the Stanford vehicle all the way until a
bolt came loose in that late lidar unit
on the top of it started wobbling and it
got really bad astigmatism and it was
crawling along and Stanley went roaring
past there the difference on this race
though is there were twenty three
finalists entering the race twenty two
of the robots got farther than sandstorm
got in the first race and five of them
finished does that look like an s-curve
to you that's an inflection point that
kind of 18-month jump I'll go in back
into that but here is the lesson of all
of this our tendency is to overestimate
short term change because of our
inflated hopes and expectations and when
cold reality fails to conform to our
inflated expectations we do the opposite
we underestimate the long term
implications this is why this is the
only slide that would argue against
being a forecaster ordinary people get
to be wrong once the internet arrives
and they go where that come from
forecasters and visionaries and software
developers and the like get to be wrong
twice because they stand at the start
and they say oh I see the future it's
just around the corner and then they
stand around course in Silicon Valley I
should add we don't draw this as an
s-curve in the valley it's a Jake
things you know just keep going upwards
forever
Garrett gruner's in the audience he'll
appreciate that this is why venture
capitalists sleep like babies they sleep
for two hours wake up and cry so now one
way and and and I should add that the
the most elegant statement of this I
ever heard was when I was a young child
living here in California kind of an a
relish part of the state and there was a
rancher who said to me son
never mistake a clear view for a short
distance and that's the best forecasting
advice anybody has ever given me and I
pass it on in the spirit of sharing
never mistake a clear view for a short
distance things will always arrive late
and in completely unexpected ways now
one way to avoid being blindsided by
this nonlinear pattern of the s-curve is
to look for indicators bill Gibson the
novelist put it very nicely at a
conference here that Kevin Kelly
organized many years ago he said you
know the futures already arrived it's
just not evenly distributed yet and he's
absolutely right and if you think about
that you know the way the way good
forecasters do it is we look for things
happening in the present and we
extrapolate out and you get tuned to
those weird little things that don't fit
that seem out of place and kind of stick
in your mind of course some of them are
hugely obvious the Keeling curve I mean
we all deserve a collective doke slap
for missing this one I mean the numbers
were there the first report I saw that
that talked about global climate change
was a NOAA report done as an expert
study in about 1977 and we still ignored
it but there are other things that are
really good indicators and doctors have
a great term for this generally I don't
use Latin in my speeches ever since I
friend historian pointed out to me after
Churchill died they were looking through
his papers and in the margins of one of
his speeches it was written he'd written
to himself speech week here use Latin
and shout
but in fact come to think of it I'm not
using Latin I'm using Greek the word
prodrome means roughly running ahead
it's an indicator now if a doctor tells
you that he sees a prodrome that's not
good news you don't want your doctor to
talk to you about pro drums but think
about pro drums of indicators things
running ahead of the actual event one of
my favorites because I was lucky enough
to notice it at the time was on the in
January 1985 on the Usenet which then
was an extraordinary obscure thing this
this guy named Spencer Bowles said I
just found an interesting software
problem of course we're gonna solve it
well the interesting software problem
was what we went on to call y2k we knew
about it then it was written up in
computer world that spring you know it
was floating around but nobody took it
seriously until about you know October
1999 so these things are all around if
you just look for them good indicators
the best indicators are things that
don't seem to fit they don't make sense
or they're just really weird and and if
you look at it that way you see them
everywhere I was flipping through the
examiner two days ago and there was a
little thing buried on page 14
San Mateo Police Department puzzled by
homemade bombs and I thought oh I so
hope that's not an indicator but I can't
get it out of my mind but let me give
you a happier example this is the Roomba
how many people here have a Roomba okay
what's the name of your Roomba sir you
doesn't okay it's great you know next
time we're gonna do a plant in the
audience forget you let me tell you what
how I found out in 2003 the Roomba came
out and something very strange started
happening I have a lot of geek friends
you know and they've got 128k max while
I did too and and and all of a sudden I
noticed some of my engineer geek friends
were totally stoked about their new
robotic vacuum cleaner and I thought
well this is odd these are people who I
don't even recall owning a vacuum
cleaner and they're excited about it and
I started checking more
and I talked to the company and they
said yeah you know we're seeing this
really weird thing to two-thirds of room
boners we've discovered given their
Roombas names and I thought I don't
remember anybody giving a vacuum cleaner
and name and then a more amazingly
one-third of Roomba owners confessed to
having taken their Roomba vacuum
cleaners on vacation with them or over
to a friend's house well folks that's a
screaming indicator that something is
going on than the robotic space and I'll
build on that in a second but then there
are just those indicators that are
really weird coincidences
the third DARPA Grand Challenge on 3rd
November 2007 and the Carnegie Mellon
team won it they finally caught up to
Stanford and they won the race but and
this was the urban Grand Challenge it
was started at 8:00 a.m. on I'm trying
to it was November 3rd and it was about
250 or I guess about a hundred mile race
and they had to drive around town and
they had to know the vehicle codes and
all this stuff and then and it was a
good race you know the the robots
actually performed but here's the
indicator at almost the exact same
moment that this race began this is what
happened on highway 99
250 miles to the north a whole bunch of
people in cars over a hundred cars in
the end I believe it was a hundred eight
cars and 18 big rigs smashed into each
other like salmon going upstream in the
fog the firemen working the front of the
accident said they could hear the cars
pounding into the back at the end at the
very same time that the robots were
taking off people were doing this okay
what's the indicator people shouldn't
drive people shouldn't Drive it's crazy
that people drive and if you ask
Sebastian's run he agrees and in fact
his forecast is by the year 2030 half of
all vehicle miles in this country will
be driven by autonomous robots which
sounds really on
until you look at this and you think at
the very moment we demonstrated 250
miles to the south that we already have
robots that understand the California
Vehicle Code better than anybody in this
room so these indicators are absolutely
everywhere but one other detail if you
miss an indicator don't worry you got
time if you miss that Usenet
announcement in 1985 you had until 1991
92 93 to get onto the bandwagon and
write your book about the y2k prices cuz
nobody else was watching it change is
slow it's uneven it's slow at the start
and then it becomes very fast so
oftentimes you can go back in mine
history for the indicators so long as
you do this look back look back twice as
far as you're looking forward Mark Twain
is alleged to observe you know history
doesn't repeat itself but sometimes it
rhymes and he's absolutely right even
though he didn't really say it there are
also people who say God darn it you
forecasters you know you use a rearview
mirror to look into the future well I'm
here to tell you a rearview mirror is a
damn good forecasting tool if you use it
in the right way because besides it's
really the only tool we have so if you
really do look back at history in the
right way it is enormous ly informative
there also you know the latest
fashionable term and forecasting because
forecasters don't get any better but
they keep changing the term and hoping
people remember you know forget their
bad history so there was a brief
horrible period where they recalled
futurologists we're glad that died and
then there are futurist doesn't quite
die and then there you know people like
me who weasel with the word forecaster
the latest term du jour is foresight is
you know somehow it makes it more
respectable so you have all these little
foresight Institute things coming up and
back well if you want to do good
foresight you better do good back sight
back sight is the secret
- foresight look back and what you can
see is that random little indicators
will suddenly line up into a very
powerful beacon looking at the future
now I've been hinting about a robot
trend let me give you some context it
turns out about every decade or so an
enabling technology arrives that sets
the entrepreneurial landscape and the
technology that shaped the 80s that
arrived in the late 70s was the
microprocessor but people didn't to
think about buying micro processors they
bought personal computers it was a
revolution because now we could have
computers on our desks so the 1980s was
a processing decade enabled by the
arrival of cheap micro processors and
the poster child was a personal computer
then the 90s however were shaped by a
fundamentally different technology by
the way in my defense this was a
forecast I actually made back then and
so I in the documentation since on my
webpage the 90s were shaped by the
communications laser which built on top
of the processing power that already
existed and cheap lasers gave us optical
storage cd-rom and most importantly they
gave us fiber optic bandwidth and that
was the XX s decade our devices were no
longer defined by what they processed
for us they were defined by what they
connected us to and by the way these are
little tiny s-curve events that that
that happened and God established and
brought some real surprises in this
decade is being shaped by fundamentally
different technologies it's not the
microprocessor it's not laser it's the
arrival oh and by the way indicators of
the laser decade I shot this on a street
in San Francisco in 1992 by the way if
you're looking for indicators in traffic
watch boat look both ways first I almost
got hit when I took his that one Wow
cool you know I gotta get a picture of
it but these things are what caused the
surprise and you know I mentioned
earlier the future tends to arrive in
unexpected ways you know think about
how the internet came in as a total
surprise to so many people in fact here
in 1987 there were people who talked
about about the fiber optics and giving
us optical storage on disk and books
were dead so no just for a moment place
yourself in 1987 and the wise people
Bill Gates was saying we have a cd-rom
revolution coming and and we're gonna
have hypertext and entire books on done
on disk and and get over bookstores
they're you know they're gonna sell your
electronic books paper books are dead
there were a few maniacs running around
like Ted Nelson and and some of Doug
Engelbart Salaam saying no no we need a
global ubiquitous hyper document system
where everything's connected to
everything and you don't have to go to
stores and they said that's very nice
maybe in 50 years the training wheels
for that are cd-rom and and hypertext on
disk but imagine saying to someone in
1987 little kids long before the year
2000 little kids will come home from
school turn on their computers log on to
a server in Tokyo download the latest
images of their favorite Japanese on he
made cartoon characters over what that
thing you thought was 50 years away the
ubiquitous global hyper document system
arrived in 1994 it was the World Wide
Web oh and by the way it triggered the
largest explosion in consumer spending
in 40 years and what was the hottest
thing being sold books they would have
locked you up as a dangerous crazy this
decade however is being shaped by an
unknown very unnoticed technology and
that's cheap sensors we are in the
middle of a vast sensor revolution of
things that are you know like RFID this
is a wonderful slide from a company that
went out of business
you know they people talked about RFID
as a substitute for barcode it may be
but for God's sake that is the least
important implication here we think
about it this way
in the 80s we created our computers in
the 90s we networked them together and
now in this decade we are giving them
eyes ears and sensory organs and what's
the only thing missing from that
put wheels on the darn things in their
robots I am here to tell you that I will
and I'm not well I'm gonna phrase this a
different way cuz I know what Stewart
will do to me
the next big thing is robots the next
big thing to come out of nowhere and
everybody's gonna know oh my god where
did that come from and I couldn't live
without that I didn't know it existed
his robots I don't know how far off it
is but it's not too far into the future
and when you look at this context from
history it's it's crushingly inexorably
obvious by the way robots may be the
next big thing they're not the only big
thing sensors pop up in other places
you're putting sensors in your running
shoes I'm sure people here have this
this is the new Nike shoe it's got a
wireless link your shoes talk to your
your iPod and if you slow down the shoes
say hey the dude slowing down switch to
the inspirational music it plays rocky
and and and this is an indicator to of
another shift by the way I mean this is
not an evening where I really wanted to
talk about forecast but I can't resist
today the web is synonymous with people
accessing information you know let's get
on there and you surf around once upon a
time the telecommunications network in
this country was about people talking to
other people and today that's such a
small fraction of what the
telecommunications network does they can
give you phone service for free over the
internet the same thing is about to
happen to the web the future of the web
is not people accessing information its
machines accessing information its
machines generating information and in
the same way that a fraction of 1% of
telecommunications traffic is
attributable to voice today in a decade
or so you will see the same thing
happened to the web where most of the
web viewing is done by machines and most
of the data is being generated by
machines but pushing onward another good
way to see indicators is to cherish
failure preferably other people's
failure remember that flat spot on the
s-curve really and truly most ideas take
20 years to be
coming overnight success in Silicon
Valley because we fail our way into the
future and by the way the valley is damn
good at failing the valley is built on
the rubble of failure not the spires of
earlier success think about why did the
web take off in Silicon Valley after all
it was invented on the Swiss French
border by an English boffin who thought
he was designing groupware for
physicists well it took off here because
a whole industry was collapsing just
before the web arrived the interactive
TV industry and it left a whole bunch of
programmers out of a job but they'd been
sensitized to rich media and video on
the like in there literally standing on
a street corner going gee what do i do
next though they see the web and they go
cool the first you know the first really
big web development company us web its
first office of any size was a building
it rented from Apple at below market
rates and Apple said oh you can have the
contents too it was the Apple
interactive TV studio but let me give
you another recent example of an
interesting failure this is from 1985
how many people here are on Second Life
charlie ants this is where it started
this is the first graphical mud multiple
user dimension habitat from Lucasfilm in
1985 wasn't around for long but
basically did everything that you do and
in second life except very slowly and it
was followed by failure after failure
after failure and then sure enough you
know in the almost almost 20 years we
get second life and the take off the
lesson here anybody who's doing an
investment or or or you want to start a
company you want a short-term win you
don't want to wait for 20 years look for
something that's been failing for 20
years and everybody has said it ain't
ever gonna happen and chances are that's
the thing that will take off this rule
is the hardest be indifferent as a for
I'm a forecaster not a futurist because
I am a professional bystander futurists
are advocates about the future
inevitably you scratch a futurist and
beneath their policy talk they are
passionate about something
personal personal helicopters or rocket
ships or preserving their their brain
and a computer or something that's fine
to be excited about the future fine to
be an advocate but engage in cognitive
dissonance when you're making the
forecast detach what you wish would
happen from what you think is likely to
happen because you get excited you
arbitrarily narrow the cone and you are
in a deep deep trouble it results in
diminished under appreciation of
uncertainty and oftentimes in just plain
old-fashioned irrational behavior like
Christian fundamentalists who believe in
the end of the world now I don't know
for sure that the world won't end but I
do know there are some people who
believe that the world war Land and
they're trying to do everything they can
to make it happen these people have been
wrong for 2,000 years and it doesn't
seem to bother them that they have the
worst forecasting record of anyone
around but being wrong I must add can
still be very profitable Hal Lindsey's
the late great planet Earth outsold
every book in the 1980s except the Holy
Bible so but it's also useful because if
you think about indicators being
everywhere the folly of other fools can
be a very powerful indicator that
something was going on and you can take
these and stick them together take
multiple events well not once I thought
about y2k for a while around 1989 1990
after the harmonic convergence of August
1987 which was the happy end of the
world
the Branch Davidians in 1993 the unhappy
end of the world and Heaven's Gate you
know they were way off in 1997 the
unhappy end there was it was cruel but
there was a bumper sticker that read so
many so few comets so many stupid people
and and a whole industry has emerged
people doing these crazy books but what
was obvious to me in the early nineties
is forget your computer forget y2k the
bug
in our computer was nothing compared to
the software bug in our culture of all
of these people who absolutely believed
this stuff and built an industry around
it and also if you look at the history
of millennial movements the biggest
impact of the prophesy happens after the
prophecy has failed to come to pass and
if we had thought hard about that we
would have understood what was going on
an indicator that I didn't figure out
but set off alarm bells for me was the
bombing of the of the Buddha by the
Taliban in Afghanistan when that
happened in spring before 9/11 I was
calling friends at the State Department
and elsewhere saying I don't get it but
this is a big deal
something's going on there is a there's
something happening in the zeitgeist I
didn't figure it out but by the way Tom
Clancy did you know he wrote a novel
five years before the fact that had a
747 flown into the White House by an
angry Japanese pilot not by those others
this is also an indicator that in my
opinion speaks to the circumstances
today we are still we are surrounded by
millennial crisis cults whether it's the
Taliban whether it is fundamentalist
Christians trying to use recombinant DNA
to create a red heifer in Jerusalem to
accelerate the second coming in my
opinion the single largest factor
affecting global politics today is the
cultural effect of the millennium and
nobody's talking about it but let me
push on to another rule assume you are
wrong whenever you make a forecast and
forecast often if you must forecast go
back look at your forecast and be
ruthless about pursuing where you are
wrong
good forecasting is the inverse of
traditional good research a good
researcher will spend a lot of time you
know carefully looking at the data
holding off coming to a theory and then
finally reach a point where he can come
to a conclusion and then ignore
everything else it doesn't match the
conclusion as a forecaster I can never
have a hundred percent information so I
do the office that I come to a
conclusion as quickly as I can and then
I set out to demonstrate why I'm
because I know if I don't do it somebody
else will explain it to me the
consequences of the failure to forecast
often we're sadly but dramatically
demonstrated on September 8 1923 on the
coast of California
south of here a couple hundred miles
this boat this destroyer the USS
Chauncey did not make it to San Diego it
was on a engineering run just after
Fleet Week in San Francisco as part of
squadron 11 destroyer force battle fleet
this is back in the old days when
destroyers huddled together
there were 14 for stackers going in a
line down the coast and they ended up on
the rocks because of a particular kind
of forecasting error actually only nine
ships made it aground the others made it
offshore and here's the story of why
they were going down the coast cruising
at about 20 knots
it's a leash or sailors know that's a
dangerous thing there was foggy weather
there was wind astern but they were
using what's known as dead reckoning
which you kind of guess at your position
in the water
navigators know what this is for lay
people dead reckoning as one Navy
skipper explained to me he says that's
that's navigation by gosh and by golly
and by God and they're calculated
position is exactly is where the dotted
line starts there this is the California
coast
just beyond Santa Barbara where the
channel turns in towards Los Angeles and
so they thought they were in just about
the right spot where they should be
turning in this area by the way is known
as the graveyard of the Pacific at least
to California sailors and the trick here
is you better make the turn right
because if you go in a straight line
you're gonna hit San Miguel Island which
they were very worried about that day
because just that morning a passenger
ship to Cuba grounded on San Miguel
Island and one of the other destroyers
the USS Reno sailed to his rescue and so
I said for God's sake let's not miss the
turn they were aware of the risk
they were also new it was high
uncertainty in their position but they
were guys and they were reluctant to
slow down because they were on an
engineering run trying to get a record
well they had some other technology they
had a good forecasting tool it was a
radio station at point argüello light
station and PK that would youwould radio
them and they would radio the bearing
that you were on the skipper of the lead
boat Lieutenant Commander hunter
requested bearings and they said you are
at 330 degree three degrees that was
consistent with the earlier bearings
they'd gotten and his navigator
lieutenant Blodgett trusted the radio
direction finder but commander hunter
was a little old-fashioned and he was
skeptical of this newfangled radio thing
and more importantly the bearing that
they gave him did not match his fix that
he had made by dead reckoning and he
thought well if it doesn't match my
position it should be wrong this is kind
of like Heaven's Gate folks Heaven's
Gate went down to Oceanside telescope
and bought a celestron c11 to look at
comet hale-bopp so they could see the
spaceship flying in behind the comet
that was going to carry them off this
planet they took it home they set it up
and they didn't see the spaceship so
what did they do they returned the
telescope because obviously it was
defective now it's not quite that bad
but the immortal words of Lieutenant
Commander hunter his instructions to
sparks his radio man quote impossible
bearing tell them we're south of
argüello dammit ask them for the
reciprocal bearing the reciprocal
bearing in those days a radio beam Conda
you can either say well you're 333
degrees or the other way and he said aha
168 degrees two miles east of my assumed
position but that ain't so bad coming
down the California coast and he issued
the fateful order at 2100 hours changed
course to 0-9 5 degrees that was their
actual position
for those of you don't know what
zero-nine-five degrees is that's a hard
left turn into the coastline the die was
cast in fact the original bearing was
right meanwhile what happened was the
Delphi his navigator wasn't the only one
harboring doubts the 11th boat back oh
by the way one of those wonderful
ironies of forecasting the lead boat was
called the Delphi you know as a
forecaster I just pray for coincidences
like so the 11th boat back the Kennedy
the Navigator there had doubts and he
violated Navy doctrine there were two
violations and Navy doctrine that night
the first one by the navigator he
listened to the radio bearings being
sent to the Delphi under destroyer
doctrine at the time only the navigator
in the lead boat was allowed to navigate
and it was against doctrine for the
other guys to even listen in he listened
and he was plotting it he's saying we're
not where they think we are and he kept
tugging the arm of his skipper commander
Roper he said we're not there Roper
agrees and Roper makes the second
violation of the evening which almost
ruined his career
destroyer doctor at the time as the
boats followed each other and you always
follow the boat in front of you and you
never varied off that because they had
really thin skins and the only safety
for Destroyers was to stick close
together and shoot all at once he as the
Delphi executed it's hard left turn onto
the coast Roper says I'm not so sure
we're gonna delay the turn and kind of
scooch a little out and sure enough they
then saw the other ships piling up he
turned out to see he led the remaining
ships to safety he was court-martialed
the lesson part of lesson is if you'll
want a piece of California geography
named after you drive your destroyer
onto the beach the mistake is
immortalized as destroyer rock just off
the California coast but the real lesson
here is about uncertainty when the
Delphi skipper hit the
rocks along with those nine other
destroyers it happened because he
narrowed his cone of uncertainty at the
very moment that the data was screaming
to widen it to hedge his bets and to
hold off and just see what the future
would bring
and his mistake is most memorialized on
this chart for all the rest of us so
unless you want to get your name on a
rock somewhere and if you really want to
understand uncertainty the lesson above
all is this embrace uncertainty in all
of its complexity and gut-wrenching
portent of change uncertainty is our
friend uncertainty is opportunity and
the last piece of advice is to really
understand uncertainty you must face
change head-on and what I love being
tuned to indicators elsewhere I didn't
even have to do a PowerPoint because I
found the indicator the best advice I've
found for forecasting it as long as I
can remember on the counter of one of my
favorite espresso bars barely 20 blocks
from here and it read this hooray for
tips ups not that part if you fear
change leave it in here that is my
advice embrace uncertainty if you fear
change leave it in here thank you
where would you like me Stewart that's
fabulous
okay smartass I'm leaving now what's
your cone of uncertainty on climate
change could you narrow I mean that's a
big topic you mean is it real okay well
here's why I look at okay yes we know
climate change is real there's no
question about that unless you're a
conservative Republican we also have
very strong evidence that it is
anthropogenic it's caused by people and
not as Russian Wack Wack tout scientists
say by changes in solar patterns but
here's the interesting question
I think the climate change has not yet
begun it's not over it hasn't yet begun
those are the two easy questions the
hard question and the real uncertainty
around it is what do we do and what I
see happening I write a column for ABC
News and the indicator that alerted me
to this was a little company that wants
to solve climate change by sprinkling
iron filings rust in the Pacific to
cause a plankton bloom and it captures
carbon they're nice folks they're very
sincere as far as I can tell it's just a
way for making money on the stock market
but I think what's happening is this
third question is dividing up into two
camps and it sort of ties to that
millennial thing the first camp call
them druids are people who say we got to
solve this problem by going lighter on
the land backing off getting things back
in equilibrium the second group called
them engineers say no no no no we got to
go faster we got to do solar shades and
of course not now we're not doing solar
shades we're doing plants if you read
last week's new scientists the study is
you've got to grow stuff on the ground
solar shades cause other problems here's
the problem we all the rest of us have
I'm I'm wofully right in the middle I've
not made in my mind one way or another
frankly I think they're both wrong you
know I reminds me of Henry Kissinger in
the first few days of the arab-israeli
war and someone said dr. Kissinger who
would you like to see when and he paused
he said it would be nice that both sides
lost the uncertainty is around who wins
the Druids or the engineers and let's
hope that debate is resolved in sensible
way a good friend of mine by the way is
hard at work on a book that sort of
touches on this subject so hurry up and
finish it Stewart and then I'll talk
about the whole climate debate largely
is going in and around the most
complicated and ambitious models in the
world and people are criticizing the
models for being jumped up weather
models other people like Jim Lovelock
are saying it doesn't have the biota in
there I suppose people at Santa Fe
Institute are saying there's not enough
complex adaptive agents wandering around
in there but models are a major
predictive tool that a lot of people use
what's your position on models well the
effectiveness the other problem between
the Druids and the engineers is druids
tend to be earth scientists and
biologists you know an earth scientist
is fundamentally a pessimist that no
matter what you do eventually the
mountains going to erode into the sea in
contrast engineers tend to be by nature
optimists there is no problem that
throwing that you can't solve by
throwing enough money and resources in
smart debt and that's the argument and I
think the value of the models depends
because the pessimist view the models
differently than the optimists the thing
I find fascinating by the way in
forecasting today is we're on a moment
where the models are getting really good
because of the combination of computer
power with Moore's law and the
algorithms and you see what the quants
did on Wall Street they're revving their
stuff and making it better all the time
it's starting to leak outwards and
frankly as a forecaster and you know
forecaster futurists call you what one
you know I I expect I will be replaced
by the Machine someday it'll do a better
job so in the
SURS get linked up to the models and
they both get smarter in terms of each
other then we get a take off that's what
we got sensors everywhere plus the
computers plus the networks you start
getting you know all I know is our
models better get a lot better real soon
because we don't have a lot of time
a question from it looks like Marga and
Novotny or raise your hand whirring or
here looks like how do you gather and
organize the indicators you've noticed
in other words what is your methodology
for keeping track with them I don't have
a good methodology yet I always carry a
camera with me I keep a good
old-fashioned paper journal I collect
stuff on the Internet what is your
journaling we've added people down in my
bag okay
he has an amazing journal which I'm
trying to persuade Stanford which they
probably will to keep because it's the
best record of these years will have
well I just remember when Stewart gave
his papers to Stanford somebody promptly
wrote a book about him there's no danger
in that case but as he said the book was
quote shockingly accurate because I'm on
the Stanford library board in that
capacity please give your papers to
Stanford but I don't have I don't have a
settled method the most important thing
is is a frame of mind I never stopped
you know it drives my poor suffering
spouse at times crazy I can remember
years ago the laser decade example we
were driving up the coast of Mendocino
is right when an emergency call boxes it
started appearing on the roadside and
right at the Mendocino line there was a
sign that said end emergency call boxes
that is damn strange and I got have to
forget the next exit drove south came on
took a picture and I just basically
ruined our weekend in Mendocino case I
picked coin what does that mean and
finally I realized what it meant
normally until that point those of you
in the room were old enough to remember
if you're driving on a road you were
assuming you were in a zone of no
communications
unless someone put up a sign that said
you can communicate here said pay phone
add dime
our world had changed thanks to the
laser that we now assumed we were in a
zone of communications to such a degree
that Caltrans felt compelled to put up a
sign st. warning you're welcome to keep
driving further north but don't blame us
if you can't get a pay phone and by the
way six months later when I drove that
Road the sign was gone because they went
all the way up the highway and then more
recently if you notice they started to
disappear because we all have cell
phones if you just keep thinking about
it all the time the indicators are there
use paper you know paper folders
computers files whatever just collect
them any way you can okay I've got two
good ones from Remy Cassio's right here
have you ever made a forecast you later
came to regret not because you were
wrong but because people who listened to
you made bad tragic or mistaken
decisions in fact something worse than
it's not quite that this is the lament
of Cassandra you know don't fall in love
or you know you know if a God you know I
I don't believe in sexual harassment but
if a God puts the moves on you
for God's sake say yes because if you
jilt them they really screw up your life
which is what happened when Apollo said
to Cassandra I give you the gift of
perfect foresight but I give you the
curse that no one will believe you now
you might think that is you know that
just having people believe your forecast
and do something wrong as bad it's worse
when they don't believe you you know and
and they come back to you say oh what I
coulda shoulda you know should have
taken your voice that's hurts because
it's your fault that's the most out of
that what how do you mmm you watch that
happen a number of times and then what
do you learn about being more persuasive
well you know a global business network
you all we're very cunning and effective
at this it's all about reports I mean
there sometimes you write a report
sometimes you give a presentation
there was an instance I know where the
way they did the report they wrote it as
a novel and got it to everyone and it
got to everyone except this one
vice-president and they gave the novel
to his wife and got him that way so you
have to be very very cunning and and
also it's it's about shaking people out
of the present Gary Snyder in one of his
poems has a marvelous passage where he
talks about a Tibetan Army knife with
patented mind opener and there are ways
to do that you take the strange and you
make it seem familiar to people and they
go oh my god or you take the familiar
and you make it seem very strange and at
that moment when their brain is in
neutral you can sing in the message
that's new you do it better than I do
another one from show me what happens
when good observers disagree for example
one guy says it's just around the corner
the other guy says what happened for
decades do you go with the guy who buys
you the better dinner I'm open to offers
I haven't had dinner yet tonight
no I to me when people disagree that's
the cone of uncertainty and and when you
hear the and oftentimes you know it can
indicate that the cone is getting very
broad or it means that there's a choke
point about to come where everything is
collapsing into you know singularity is
a bad bad term carrying lots of baggage
but things you know events collapse into
a point where it all happens multiple
voices are great the more the better
well that raises question from Jim cor
is it for you over here how and when do
you know the S curve is shaped some are
shallow some are rather steep what's
what's the early indicators of which one
you're looking at I don't know I spend a
listen we should we should meet for a
beer afterwards this gets kinda into
deep geek part about forecasting and
this is actually something I'm looking
at very closely right now part of my
work at Stanford I haven't found an
effective way except in a rough
heuristic instinctive
analogies to other things to figure out
what what the steepness is and that's
why all of the s-curves I drew were
idealized death curves don't use them as
actual forecasts by the way he also had
a question it's kind of interesting y2k
in some sense was bust if I was one of
the people who said it's going to be the
end of the world and I was hilariously
wrong I'm still not convinced you're
right about nuclear power you okay
loudly the end of the world so what we
won't care right okay what my probably
nuclear power by the way I think it's a
great idea if we had enough swedish
engineers to run the plants but well
thanks to us greenies we've you know
there are any smart nuclear engineers
right now they're all in France though
we can import French ones
all right y2k was a bus was that because
the software developers solved the
problem or because there actually was no
problem no I think was it was the first
it was you know and and I was in the
middle of the time I was advising a lot
of IT departments and said look at this
interesting problem you better handle it
now it's sort of like sailing a sailboat
around an island you know if you make a
small course change ten miles off it's a
lot easier than making a big course
change a hundred yards off the reef the
longer you wait the more expensive it's
going to be to fix and the more you're
gonna get slammed by your CEO and and
you know CIOs they're the Rodney
Dangerfield's of management they don't
get no respect I mean think about this
just degress this was a real problem
about y2k is it was a lose-lose
situation if it collapsed it would have
gotten fired if it didn't collapse they
would said it was Miami think of this
the CFO goes CIO goes into the CEOs
office and an ordinary company in this
country and he says here's let me tell
you the details its CEO says I don't
need to know details just tell me the
bottom line if a CEO did that to the CFO
walks in and said you know well let me
talk about the financials and he says I
don't need to know details just a bottom
line CEO would be fired
so the Brill problem with y2k is CIOs
got no respect but it was solved because
a lot of people did a lot of hardware
but sadly and unfortunately it
distracted us from what the real issue
was and and the I did a column in salon
magazine that the title was forget your
computer worry about the wacko down the
street and I got three death threats off
of it from actually the ended up
becoming very good friends with a guy
who as near as I could tell live two
ridges over from where Ted Kaczynski
lived but it's an hour story so what we
have now is y2k is an example of an
accurate prediction which was self
canceling yeah happens all the time
that's the whole point of predicting you
know the whole point of mapping that
code of uncertainty is to steer yourself
away from the bad things and towards the
good things so this is a way for
forecasters to take credit when they're
wrong it's working for me for 20 years
but you better have a credible case I
mean if nobody had done anything to the
computers and we hadn't had a problem
then then if we could have said y2k
wasn't a problem but a lot of people did
put a lot of man-hours into it
absolutely and if we got rid of a lot of
legacy systems and upgrades in them yeah
okay
IBM sold a whole bunch of hardware yeah
it keeps happening Kevin Kelly asks he's
right here how might our methods this is
a metaphor casting question just what
you need how might our methods say the
one you just outlined the forecasting
change in the next twenty years is there
any technology or culture that will
change forecasting itself well I think
the biggest change is that we're going
to end up having forecasters are going
to have professional forecasters are
going to have lots of conversations with
machines and I think what's going to
happen to forecasting is a little bit
what happened to the natural sciences
and biology in the 70s and 80s you know
we're today you can't be a P PhD student
in biology unless you're a computer
chuck you know and and 30 40 years ago
you didn't have to know computer stuff
in biology
yes degree in biology I'm in trouble
here
so for professionals they're going to
lots more conversations with much more
sophisticated tools and for non
professionals ie consumers of forecast
they're going to have to understand more
about what the tools are that the
professionals are leaning on and so I
think we're gonna that inevitably is
going to change the metaphors and change
the conversation in the vocabulary
forecasting ok biology I don't think I
satisfied him molecular biology is
pretty predictive that sounds
everything's taking off in the area I'm
not saying it's the predictive but I'm
listen even even behavioral biologists
you know ecologists are there carry
laptops out in the field and they're
pulling data and they're gonna get
sensors and all that I'm not saying it's
predictive but I'm saying they're using
the tools ok same thing for forecasters
you got my point ecology I can promise
you as an ecologist is not predictive
yeah absolutely
yeah but but they use lots of computers
right and we're headed in the it makes
them feel good it's getting that and
it's also getting more predictive yeah
close call you should try this sometime
having a conversation with Stewart in
front of 300 people
200,000 people actually a lot of them
are not actually the only thing I only
think works in this story was there's a
little book I helped put together of
some collection of [ __ ] White's essays
and the editor called me and sweet-talk
me said well would you help and by the
way would you do the introduction and I
said sure and 48 hours later I went what
have I just done you know putting my
words in front of EB White's but then I
remembered nobody reads introduction so
it wasn't a problem that was before
video now everything's in there
Donna Carlson Dan Carlson Dan Carlson
sorry a couple years ago I discovered a
list online of the top 100 world
economies 50 work countries and 50 were
corporations I figured that 50 years ago
all 100 would have been countries is
this a trend in 50 years will they all
be corporations and if so how many the
top 100 will be 100 right I you know you
would have to give me a little bit more
time than we have you know in the 30
seconds to try and give you a number it
is actually a subject I'm thought about
a fair amount I've actually taken that
shift of corporate versus national
economy size in a slightly different
direction
bear with me you assume that
nation-states will stay around I don't I
I think the 20th century was we without
a doubt this is a safe forecast the 20th
century was definitely the century where
the nation-state dominated international
affairs and in a strict legal sense
until the UDI the Universal Declaration
of Human Rights that was true classical
public international law the only person
to do international law person as an
entity that's recognized as a
nation-state I think what we're seeing
we have more nation-states today than
ever but the nation-state is beginning
to fly apart and I think it doesn't mean
nation-states are going to disappear but
political power at an international
level in my opinion is shifting to a
different body and
the century and that's the city state
and that city-states are going to be the
entities that call the shots either
directly as independent defect or day
you are a city states like Singapore or
Dubai or as de facto city-states like
Shanghai and Beijing you know China is
an interesting place the most powerful
politicians in the country are the
mayors and and eventually I was true
here too and it and that's why I mean
it's true here too let me give you an
example in this country I actually think
it's an open question whether the United
States will exist in a recognizable form
by the middle part of this century
because we're flying apart one Enriquez
was here and he talked about the Untied
States that was part of it the other
piece is we have a bunch of regions in
this country that are already acting as
independent city-states I mentioned you
know the Bay Area in some ways is a
city-state Southern California la San
Diego California a city-state is the
logical unit of size it's big enough to
have an impact in the international
marketplace but it's small enough that
everybody sees their relationship to the
whole and that's its power and we have
good examples but just one extended
example here from California Arnold
Schwarzenegger two years ago George Bush
came to me said Arnold I need your
troops on the California border to
protect us down to the Mexican border
against terrorists and illegal aliens so
send the National Guard down there and
what did the Republican Governor of
California say to the Republican
president a member of his own party no
and what did he to a month and a half
later he held a press conference on the
shore of San Francisco Bay with a real
head of state Tony Blair announcing a
joint alliance between California and
the UK around a policy involving global
warming and direct opposition to his
Republican president the United States
is breaking up into city-states I think
it's inexorable I think it's going to
happen the only uncertainty and I'm
spending a lot of time
about this now ease what does it do is
it in kind of a soft you know Europeans
are you know from Venus kind of approach
or is it in kind of a nasty you know
civil war style Americans are from Mars
and we can't get along that's the
uncertainty but your question to me
really is what's the role of the
city-state and the spoiler in that and
there's lots of complexity I think
there's some interesting conflicting
forces going on here you bet I've so
completely agree with the urbanization
overwhelm which is going on there and
yet and yet so that's sort of the
opportunity space is being filled by
cities in ways that nations can't keep
up with the communications and all these
other things you're talking about how
about the problem space say climate
change is the major dominant
overwhelming everybody's got to deal
with it how are they going to deal with
in problem space we're looking at over
the next half century at least cities
are not going to be able to step up to
climate who steps up to climate is
basically for national elements the
European Union the United States China
and it if those four governments
national governments do the right thing
we might be okay if they don't we won't
cities are not part of that story yeah
so what does that do to nationhood well
this is where the uncertainty comes in I
mean this gets in I you know it would be
a very nice thing to have nation-states
a stolid it'd be nice maybe they have a
global government that could handle some
of these things and like but you know
oftentimes events go in an opposite
direction
think about what prop 13 did for this
state and the disastrous consequences it
had for education and on and and now
today the whole attitude of about
property ownership and this
fundamentalist approach is working
against a lot of the global climate
change stuff and and at all sorts of
levels you know there are I think the
number is 70 property owners on the
Mexican US border who are being sued by
the federal government because they
won't allow surveyors on the border to
survey them for the border fence so I
would you're absolutely my waterfront
property is
completely swamped by rising sea-levels
who do I sue I don't know it probably
won't matter but there probably will be
a little interesting you know there will
be lawyers around to a handle it but
this is the problem that the
nation-state is waning at exactly a time
when we need national we need national
power and we need national presence
there are more actors on this on the
international stage not less and that's
going to create confusion question for
them Ricardo Ricardo is where the
greater or getting there the greater the
information environment the greater the
cone of uncertainty right what effects
size of cones of uncertainty I think
it's the larger question here I'm not
when are they narrow when are they wide
it's not it you know it's a heuristic is
not empirical when they're really why do
you feel it you just know it like when
the Berlin Wall fell that was a point as
a forecaster where to me you know I took
the advice of my mother she said there
are times when children should be very
small and very quiet because it went to
180 degrees but barely six months later
in August
Saddam Saddam's tanks crossed the border
into Saudi Arabia and we did not go to
DEFCON two and at that point it was very
clear what the order would be and in my
opinion it was it marked the this entry
really ended when Saddam's tanks rolled
across the border because we had nted
and we'd left the bipolar world and gone
into a multipolar world and then it was
pretty clear what things look like so
oftentimes what I look for is that key
indicator event that says wait a second
something just changed so was that a
narrowing of the cone when you saw them
yeah absolutely
okay one more from Kevin Kelly I think
we'll stop here if the world is
accelerating by the way that at that
comma he wants you to know if you agree
or disagree I'm agnostic on this you
know does he reckon actually the
agnosticism accelerating
what it is is the individual pieces the
reason my hypothesis about why things
take 20 years is because people are
stubborn and they don't change their
minds
you know they formed their ideas and
they get 20 years on the stage to
implement them they get shoved off and I
haven't noticed that people have gotten
any less stubborn the acceleration
effect we feel in my opinion is
happening because more things are
happening at once and as a forecaster
the real change again this is you know I
didn't want to bore you all tonight the
real change comes from the cross impact
of multiple events reinforcing each
other or dampening each other it's not a
singer airlie a single event and the
acceleration effect we feel is it's just
because there are more people and
there's more going on and also above all
you know the difference between this
moment in time and trying to put
ourselves into the shoes of someone in
1914 is we know how it turned out for
them so we really can't understand what
it was like to be them we don't know how
it turns out for us and that gives us
that getting sort of pit in the stomach
feel you get when you go down a roller
coaster and if we had perfect foresight
and could see everything then it
probably wouldn't feel like such an
acceleration well the there's
technologies have self accelerating or
not capabilities there are individual
things that accelerate otherwise we
wouldn't have s-curves the question to
me is when it really Nets you know net
net bottom line for our life when it
really nuts out do we feel an
acceleration and I've talked to you know
someone a few it was long sometime ago
someone was over a hundred years ago who
had been through the changes of the late
1800s you know it sort of seen what Reed
Henry Adams wonderful book the education
of Henry Adams you know the chapter the
Virgin and the Dynamo and and also you
know like all this acceleration stuff is
almost become a religion the quarter
just started in Stanford and I had my
first class today and the first reading
I signed to my class was an essay titled
the law of acceleration it was not
written by a Silicon Valley geek it was
written in 1904 by Henry Adams so people
are going
things are accelerating for a long time
and I can show you quotes from
frustrated scribes in 1503 going movie
things are accelerating so so I would
just kind of yeah they're accelerating
but I you know there's this historic
chauvinism that every every human alive
at the moment they've been alive has
thought they lived in the most important
time in history and it was because we
didn't know how it would turn out and
we're no different and and we have the
Internet to remind us where the most
important in history look are we done
yet not quite let me let me stay on your
field on technology for America's some
technologies do not self accelerate
nuclear technology just not actually
Three Mile Island Chernobyl I can slow
itself down
it doesn't feed into its own research
whereas computer ly computer technology
feeds into its own research
biotechnology feeds into its own
research nanotechnology which is
becoming biotechnology feeds into its
own research so they self accelerate you
suggested a minute ago that those things
are intersecting what happens when a
couple of exponential curves intersect
do they become hyper exponential what's
going on am I supposed to talk about the
singularity now well we've had a couple
talks on the subject one is saying is
you know your future is a black hole the
other who was it who said this thing was
it you said the singularity will happen
but we won't notice that's Danny Hillis
that was Danny okay um also let me put a
pitch for another book in here Kevin
Kelly is working on a marvelous book the
Technium and he is going to actually
answer this question this stuff is out
of catalytic without a doubt the
technologies do interact and at times
you know they own us we don't own them
from biology what we know is things that
are auto catalytic it's called cancer
yeah brake brake yeah it's not good so
innovation too is you know I think in
biology is an innovation called mutation
and there is no infinite J curve is that
what you're telling us there all this
curve so that we like it or not oh
actually s curves go down
the other piece there yeah we things
eventually things eventually level off
the reason why it looks like a big-ass
curve is that they enter finger I'm
reminded of that marvelous story of the
little old lady who went up to Carl
Sagan in the basement Harvard Science
Center after you given the talk and she
said Sonny I like to hear talk but but
you know I know what it really is it's
the world is on the back of a turtle
carrying it through time and Sagan you
know smart Cornell professor he says
well but what's the turtle on and she's
another turtle so what says Sonny I'm
Way ahead of you it's Turtles all the
way down well big s curves are made of
lots of little s curves and they enter
finger and it would be cruel to go into
details tonight but that's why we get
big s curves because of the interaction
of all the smaller s curves all the way
down and all the way up I don't know yet
thank you for coming tonight
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you